welcome to this video yeah a new game
that I played in the European club cap
in Bilbao about two weeks ago and yeah
this is the second game of the event for
me was the fourth round of the
tournament has already um explained in
the first video of the series I had
missed the first two rounds due to leak
game in Germany so the third round we
played my Belgium team played against
her team from austria from Zod's book
and i was playing on board 5 and my
opponent was a feed master still is a
feed master almond ooh-rah kovitch from
bosnia actually bosnian um national team
um guys a feeder mask is rated 2000 2345
at the time and my preparation was some
yeah pretty brief to be honest because
it was a quite surprising experience he
has a good rating 2345 but I only had
like 80 90 games in the database which
is very very few um to compare um I've
got like three hundred fifty games in
the database and this is for a playoff
my strength very very small number I
didn't place so much over the years and
his 90 games is like like nothing so it
was a very difficult time to prepare and
he also had switched around with
openings and however what I did
recognize is from the preparation this
person had gained rating points in the
last year's like very constantly each
list he gained like 10 20 rating points
which showed me that he was pretty much
constantly playing above his level and
he even had gained recently points to
come from 2200 something above tooth
300 so it is play made a very decent
impression on me so I was thinking okay
let's go play it safe play Knight f3
yeah one reason for 93 years I mix it up
between d4 Knight f3 sometimes c4 and he
was playing some kind of be Nonis
blumenfeld this kind of openings and I
didn't really feel well prepared against
those so I wanted to have a slightly
quite alive clay night every see form
and here he had mostly played lines like
II 60 b6 yeah something something like
that was so in the games or or even the
odd Queens gambit um however he
surprised me in the game we played g6
which he never had played before so any
preparation that this case was brief was
obsolete basically yeah the Kings Indian
and yeah here White has a slight choice
most people play Bishop e2 without even
thinking that much it is the main line I
have played h3 quite often he also in my
blitz games if you have watched some of
my channel is shreya play very
frequently however I recently have
looked at some lines in the classical
with Bishop e2 and this is why I played
Bishop e2 in this game I wanted to to
try those so those lines out however he
played c5 okay so naughty five the main
Kings Indian move but c5 yeah c5 is a
very decent alternative actually it is
rarely played because it does not fit so
well within the Kings Indian in in one
or two lines and exactly the line that
we have on the board now or get on the
board is one of the reasons um it is in
fact quite interesting to play for black
if white plays d5 we transpose to a
benoni
where black is already I guess quite
happy to see the set up with Bishop e2
and not with Bishop d3 or yeah let alone
anything where the f porn is involved so
this is a pretty decent benoni white can
play that of course but certainly
something that black does not mind and
my opponent had experience in the Benoni
I quickly played castles which is the
main move here anyway um it basically
invites black to take on d4 and
transpose into the very well known Roxy
bind black in fact does not have really
a better move some people try to play
knight c6 here to stay yeah out of the
more oxy and but here g5 is a good line
for white after d5 black it was his time
with this night he needs to misplace it
on a five or get a double porn after
9055 it's not really great so my
opponent also took on deform ok so i
captured he went 96 Bishop e3 the more
oxy bind normally coming from the
Sicilian accelerated dragon or sometimes
out of English openings like c4 c5 now
we come to a first small point point
point he now took on d4 I think this is
a good move order for black to be honest
lots of people play this move which is
the arguably the main line after Bishop
e7 white however has the opportunity to
play the move Knight see to a move that
for years has been I think and actually
underestimated in recent years it has
become clear that this is a strong
option um yeah to be honest I I have
suspected this for ages i play this move
like since i played this whole opening
because it was recommended to me by a
friend and i have a fantastic score with
the structure keeping more pieces on the
board black is somewhat cramped he's got
many pieces all pieces in fact for
little space and he likes to exchange
pieces this is why black really here
took the chance to get this night off
first and then play Bishop d7 yeah he
tries to take he tries to reverse the
moves so to say in the other move order
Bishop d7 white sometimes play squinty
do this is the word mainline not create
not night c2 and after that leg captures
and plays this move and what he does in
the game or tries to do in the game is
to get the transposition of moves he
took first takes Bishop d7 yeah enter
here I must admit that I had a hard time
to remember if this move order has any
substantial drawback I actually looked
this up now and hound out that one way
to try to to punish black for this more
order is the move Queen to d3 I thought
I briefly thought about it during the
game but then I thought that okay come
on let's let's just play the the normal
main line which is also a comfortable
option so I didn't go go for that the
idea of Queen d3 is that it lands
additional protection to the e4 pawn
there might be something like that
happening Bishop c6 and now F for this
is a big difference to the Queen
placement on d to with the Queen on d to
white basically is forced to lend
further protection to e4 like Bishop e3
Bishop d3 and here the queen is
protecting that something like this is
rather attractive position for why this
was recently reached in a in the game
between Austria number one Marcus hugger
against Mamedov in Dubai 2014 I think
this is probably a blitz or rapid game
from this huge event however it's a it's
a good day good line yeah this Queen d3
is very interesting I didn't go for that
I just played Queen d2 sort of allowing
the transposition to the traditional
main line Bishop c6 here takes the e4
pawn I cover that black place a 5 yeah
a5 is a typical move what black wants to
do is he wants to secure the c5 square
for is night the square this is the idea
the night wants to come to c5 and this
is what he's doing now I played be three
yeah making sure that after move like a
four I go before and have a good
structure on the queenside with the upon
being potentially week of course he went
97 and here an important moment it is
clear that white has all the pawns on
light squares almost all of them and the
dark squared bishop and you definitely
very rarely want to exchange your dark
squared bishop when you have to so many
pawns on dark side on light square so
your dark squares would be severely
weakened after the trade I definitely
want to keep the bishop on the board so
we should be three Black Plague 95 and
this also initiates a typical regrouping
that he's now getting it Queen to be six
look F to c8 and Queen to d8 back so
this kind of real whooping Queen here
and roop here and then the Queen
probably wants to drop back what is
White's plan White has basically two
main plans he can drive to advance on
the queenside with a 3 and B for this
would be nice to get in however there's
some pressure on b3 and the whole Queen
side not so easy to do I am preparing
this I play rook a b-1 he went Queen B 6
and now look FC one this is a good prep
move that covers the c3 night as well
yeah black played rook f2c 8 yeah
joining the action on the queenside yeah
here is an interesting an interesting
moment if I go a 3 now a 3
you can look at this it looks it looks
to be yet but this is hanging need to be
very cautious with with moving pawns on
the queenside I want everyone to further
strengthening of the position I went
Roxy to Roxy to yeah this has multiple
ideas one ideas if black now tries to
play a move like that trying to prevent
a three-wide even has this move Quincy
one to push the Queen back looks it too
as a as a move that as soon you that is
a that is a theoretical move um yeah
black of course didn't play Queen before
he went just back to the eighth here
getting out of this this pin yeah now if
white now tries to play this this space
gaining move with a three the move a4
comes into consideration for black the
point being that all of a sudden aight
is starting a weird invasion on b3 so
this is not convinced as well what wide
needs to do is he needs to prepare
further I went to Bishop to everyone
oops not that ship to f1 Bishop to f1
yeah and what about this move what does
it do it allows further strengthening of
the position by white mainly the idea
night e 2 2g for one night b5 2595 he
might take so the bishop esm is giving
me an additional option to to free the
e2 square it's also a good strengthening
move the bishop on everyone is getting
out of the way of of some pieces it also
asks black what are you doing next black
now went queen to f8 and a weird-looking
move at first what is the point it has a
point blacks at DM is to play there are
two things it could be Bishop to f6 and
then Queen to g7 building up pressure on
the long diagonal the second idea could
be aged five king to age seven let's get
rid of some of those aged five king to
age 7 and then Bishop to h6 is changing
the dark squared bishop as mentioned i
want to keep those bishops on the board
and a trade would definitely be
something that black welcomes yeah here
I really wasn't sure how to continue and
after a moment I came up with night g5
um I wasn't I wasn't really sure because
I have little experience in this precise
position I have far more experienced
when the night is on c2 when i get this
retreat i'm going in yeah 95 the idea is
simple might be six wins in exchange
yeah so black is basically obliged to
take the piece it's a very often a big
problem on not a big problem but a big
feature of those maroc see buying
structures the knight on d5 is a very
very annoying piece and black it's very
often not really able to play e6 and to
drive it away here it loses the exchange
of six but also in general if he tries
to prepare that like 97 Becky 6 that's
all cause lots of time and at the end
the d6 pawn will be weak so one problem
of the maroc see is that this post on d5
is very annoying black very often it's
basically forced to take the piece and
this is what he did he took on d5 yeah
here we come to an interesting moment
I'm actually when we reach this position
I of course had played 95 with the idea
to capture with the upon which is the
the normal recapture if we look at the
recaptures the
this one is maybe slightly more
interesting than usual because I'm yeah
I'm already close to doubling on the C
file and I have this this square but
still the capture with the seaport is a
bit lame because very likely there will
be trades on the C file and the whole
structure is symmetrical it's difficult
to really get some some opening of the
position n so this I have discarded
quite quickly and eat xt5 it's the way
it normally is played just from a
structural point of view I didn't know
the exact position but this is what
normally is done the deep horn is there
to make sure that the epon only seven is
not moving easily it should be only see
only seven and what white is trying to
do is long-term to get pressure against
the porn like let's say both rooks here
and then pressurize the is heaven porn
this is some the way it is normally
played yeah I have found some games with
that like they could could go like that
there is it actually here yeah something
like Luke c7a 3b6 Bishop g5 and dryer
here this concrete game black weakened
to himself a bit this was between um
oops former did I just delete the whole
thing I guess I'm sorry jumping back but
it's quickly between fillmore theater
world champion hikes on the ha'la'tha
monett the german german player Steve
unbound um yeah he txt five is a good
choice and of course i was aware that
this is the normal way to to take
however when i was sitting there I was
thinking hmm well what about Queen d5
nobody ever takes with the Queen is this
a bad move and I wasn't sure I thought
that it could be an interesting idea I
never saw it really that
someone is taking with with a piece so I
went for it yeah it seems to be worse
objectively speaking than the e pawn
capture but I was our somehow
interviewed by the idea to do that um
yeah I was thinking isn't this maybe
it's still a bit of an advantage for
what I have this idea so to play a three
before and if I get in a three before
which seems likely that i did I manage
that then even c5 might count like
before and c5 ultimately that also with
prima bishop I was thinking I isn't is
still a slight advantage maybe maybe and
I can so I don't see how black is
equalizing easily are making a draw it's
clear that I'm not threatening to win
upon what we what we can look at he went
Bishop age six which is a good move I I
definitely don't want to grab a pawn
here that that's very important um yeah
black black cancer I mean apart from the
fact that this Queen looks like it's
getting trapped I'm not sure at the
moment if this happens but also the dark
squares are so weak I don't want to do
that also this this for example if we
just look at this from a strategic point
of view black getting the bishop here on
this fantastic square this is just
rubbish for what never what never ever
should allow that like it says far
better here so that's really no option I
want to keep it on the board so Bishop
not taking of course but Bishop f2 yeah
he surprised me I didn't really I didn't
really expect at the next move but it
was a good news he played a good game
here anyway it was a there was just one
one soft spot Roxy six
I was surprised because I thought that
this rook is somewhat clumsily plays
when a three before it's but we see a
three he went to Bishop f4 be form takes
takes and night back to the seven yeah
and here an interesting moment I went c5
I could have considered to play g3
immediately but this this looked looked
a bit lame to me if I go g3 you just
that say he just sorry it just drops
back I go see five yeah i'm using this
the spin of the the deep on but you can
just play rook c7 this is really a
problem myrick 1 C 2 is unprotected so
I'm not really threatening to take on d6
and blankets maybe just going here with
the tempo and then it will take the
ablex position is very very compact he
has little weaknesses so this is not
really really great um yeah I decided to
play c5 immediately queen age 6 g3 and
Bishop e3 so black finally got this got
this straight and that he what he wanted
all the time I still thought I might
have a slight pool I went Bishop b5 and
he went rook c7 I think this is
necessary black does not have anything
dramatic like this for example I just
take the the rook this is just just
check really and here black is out of
any firepower he only attacks with the
night end that's not nothing happening
here he has to play rook c7 but it is it
is sufficient roop c7 yeah yeah and here
I was slowly but surely recognizing that
I really don't have anything here at the
end I took on d7 and played b5 my only
idea left is a passed pawn the C porn
yeah and in fact i get i get this pawn I
could have played mc6 immediately by the
way take
takes but he goes there b5 and after
something like that Queen III secures
good counter play yeah the queen is
entering yeah something like that and
it's just like he's defending with all
heavy pieces and my king is also
slightly insecure I really don't have
any winning chances here it's debatable
what's what's what's tougher if this is
was maybe a bit more a bit more testing
than what I did I'm really not sure yeah
I played as mentioned i played b5
immediately he played rukka c7 and i
went c6 establishing the pawn yeah now
black has a very forcing continuation
that he also played black tux black took
took on f2 look checks and queen III
setting up this pin very annoying yeah
my rook is not participating here to
support my porn yeah I went King g2 and
he played Quincy five yeah we see that
black some mex forces are working well
together yeah he's putting pressure on
the c6 porn I really don't don't have
any any way forward Tim I can for
example if I trade here he will take
luke be seven and he just takes him and
then marches the sea upon which is which
is a very draw position probably it will
end in a draw I wanted to test him a bit
more I mean yeah not like it had huge
hopes but I wanted to try to play a bit
more complicated I went instead of the
screen capture I went rook b7 played
rugby 7 yeah and here yeah I was hoping
for something like Quincy 6 which is
which is of course not very good but ok
didn't didn't didn't fail for that of
course i mean when i say hoping it's not
like expecting but there are those
things in the position if black takes on
c6 with
the rook by the way I will probably just
trade and we get a comparable position
to what we had before I was in fact
quite surprised a bit surprised that he
that he answered with a different move
he went a rook a to c 8 yeah okay I mean
this is not spoiling anything or or
whatever but I still thought the other
thing is easier i went through k2
intending ruka a seven again and now now
to be honest now came the surprise here
I was really thinking okay yeah I'm
threatening to take c5 and play look a
seven and yeah but what we should
probably just takes his six now and we
just continue from there with the equal
position but it played e6 which was
really shocking I thought wow why is the
why is this happening now I took on c5
and I could play rook a 27 and this is
dangerous now a bit black of course
cannot take because I take with the pawn
and then ruka 8 will will promote my
beep oh so very easy win which means as
I'm threatening rook takes 27 he only
has the root caption after which I all
of the Sun enter on the 7th rank yeah
very nice i have doubled rooks on the
7th rank and this kind of active rooks
also mean that i have a draw in the back
by the way I'm he went c4 didn't have
much time you only had little time left
so I have a draw in the bag i can always
give checks on the 7th and it means that
I'm the one playing for wind as I can
decide when the game should end or if I
ever want to want to continue and now
now here I really made a mistake and end
a huge one because i was thinking in
this position okay yeah i can give a
check on g7 just follow my train of
thought I
give a check on g7 his route King moves
if he moves to age eight I take on age
seven check King g8 and I give check on
g7 again so i have just won a pawn in
the process with the check it shouldn't
be it should help me in a play rook g7
check he goes king of eight I take age
seven threatening made on h8 he needs to
go back to g8 and again I can give the
check on his hand so I have just won a
pawn for for nothing so I thought okay
let's go for that he had little time on
the clock had a little bit more it was
not like an hour or whatever but I had a
head-to-head a sufficient time to think
about but he had no time I gave this
check anti relatively quickly went to
evade and here without thinking very
much I took h7 he went back and I gave
the check again so i have just netted
this pawn however here in this precise
position White has a way because king of
eight was the huge blunder my problem
and this was very very stupid thing I
was thinking before and ok I take h7 and
that took there quickly um I have a win
and the wind is not very difficult to
spot actually I can give the check here
on f7 King e8 and now there's more than
one win but the most convincing win is e
five the idea of e 5 is to take on h7
then move the rook away and then mate
this is really a mate in like the mating
idea in one two three moves and black
has no defense absolutely no defense
it's quite quite fascinating here I has
no defense against us let's say he plays
Rock c5 just to give a sample on here
takes him
I go look at seven and that's it well
it's it's it's really it's a it's really
nice or wait and we can play look a fire
Kenny oh wait just a moment so this is
the most most precise way to do it
oh look a is seven look at five hmm not
not totally sure I can go here this is
strong I really have the time I have the
time to cover a five and then then get
in Luke a 7 and this arc analysis this
is the point okay so what is winning
like that however I think instead of e 5
by the way I can also just take the jury
also went here he has this defense of
try but this is of course far far better
than then the game and also should win
yeah my problem was really that I did
not calculate really i was just
beforehand having this kind of logical
train of thought like I give the check
and no matter where he goes I would win
upon and I didn't really think about it
when he went king evade I was just
playing rook h7 as I had two other had
planned Luke af7 would've won yeah i
took that he went back to g8 i gave the
check again quickly as planned and now
whoops he went 2 h8 haha okay and yeah
now that's it with the win the direct
win yeah let's take stock White is a
pawn up and he has doubled on the
seventh rank but how are you going to
win this is a super dangerous porn I
really took a long time him and at the
end came to the conclusion and rightly I
think the right sorry the right
conclusion I just need to retreat marks
and fight against the sea porn there is
no other way to try to play for win also
it should be mentioned that the the
match was super super close affair at
the end and ended with with the 33 time
so I knew
we needed to be very very circumspect
not not blundering as something and let
the Sepoy promote or whatever so need to
be cautious I went with number of chicks
and now to d7 yeah going all the way
back stopping the sea pawn and now black
really has counterplay he went in five
this is a good move King F to roots III
and here we see the counter play the
rook from c3 attacks the f porn and this
rook is also attacking their pond after
King e2 he went rogue evade and this is
a counter play that is strong enough to
secure a draw it is really really
nothing that I can do it I went Rocky
III which basically accepts the draw and
I could also go rook d2 but then he will
take I take here note that this is a
funny way to blunder the whole thing
yeah so mad or not yeah I went Rocky III
he captured gave the check yeah and here
i have no no way forward at first I was
thinking okay maybe I can go here and
after here Kingda tool but he just has
rook c4 and I have no no way forward
really King bee three rock before and he
will get the pawn back yeah that's
that's really not not helping at the end
um I went I went here oh sorry I took it
I took it check when she get the pawn
back yeah here we actually yeah we could
have agreed to a draw but I wanted to
continue but I'm still a bit more active
with the king but black got the porn
back my only very very slight hah Busta
the better activity but of course black
black skin is in front of the e porn so
even if he loses the the g6 bond it's
not not any problem yeah he played
normal moves moves that were totally
sufficient to to keep the draw yeah g4
he can just give it away and now we'll
get with the king the other near the
pond here we reached him the the
backings and agreed to it raw so draw in
my second game in fact this this this
match was really funny it ended 33 as
mentioned with six drawers but all
drawers were fought to back kings or
ever till the end yeah so a very tough
match against this Austrian team and I
think this was a I think that draw
actually was a very fair result in a way
he only here blundered at one move with
King evade which I've held to do that
which I fail to take advantage of
because I was not thinking at the point
at this point i was just playing the the
intended moves with rook takes h7 and it
didn't i didn't really think about that
this is a different issue king fa de IH
eight so it was it was a stupid thing so
here i could have at one point one quite
quite easily but other than that the
game was pretty much in a in a state of
equilibrium it was very very equal i
think he defended well so yeah a draw
here fair result i believe i hope you
enjoyed the analysis thanks for watching